How metal was that Eddie Munson moment in
the "Stranger Things" Season 4 finale?!
And why was it the perfect choice for the
character?
Keep watching as we break it all down.
"Stranger Things" fans have had a painstakingly
long wait for the final feature-length episodes
of Season 4, after Volume 1 arrived on May
27, but Netflix has finally released the last
two chapters, and they drastically change
the future of the hit series.
While the end of Volume 1 revealed that the
terrifying villain, Vecna, is not only Henry
Creel but also One, Volume 2 mainly revolves
around the gang's attempt to kill him by using
Max as bait.
After all, he's already had a taste of her
pain and he wants to finish the job.
This is partly because Vecna's master plan
involves ripping open four gates across Hawkins
using four deaths as a way of bridging the
real world with the Upside Down.
The stakes have never been higher, and there's
been talk of a tragic death in the series
since before this season started.
So it's a little nerve-racking when Steve,
Nancy, and Robin all lie in wait for Vecna
at the Creel house while Dustin and Eddie
keep the Demobats [DEM-oh-bats] distracted
with an impromptu metal concert at the trailer
park.
Unfortunately, the battle comes at a high
price for Eddie.
The leader of the Hellfire Club has been a
big focus this season since the Hawkins townsfolk
think he's responsible for the deaths of Chrissy,
Fred, and Patrick.
It's all down to the (very real) satanic panic
that gripped the United States in the 1980s,
which led many to believe that Dungeons & Dragons
was part of some sinister evil plot to corrupt
young people.
"These murders are ritualistic sacrifices!"
Although Eddie spends most of his time hiding
and going on the run, he armors up to help
Steve, Nancy, Robin, and Dustin in the Upside
Down.
Eddie's idea of distracting the Demobats is
a pretty inspired one — he grabs the Upside
Down version of his electric guitar and climbs
on top of the trailer to absolutely shred
Metallica's "Master of Puppets" as a siren
song to draw the Demobats away from the Creel
house.
It's an act that fits his character perfectly,
since he's a metalhead as well as a Dungeon
Master.
It's a pretty appropriate song choice too,
since Vecna is also a master of the Upside
Down.
The scene allows Eddie to let loose for a
few minutes after spending days hiding in
the woods by Lover's Lake — he just gets
lost in the music, knowing that it's helping
in the fight against Vecna.
"Are you ready for the most metal concert
in the history of the world?"
Eddie's performance is another example of
how powerful music can be in the series.
After all, Kate Bush's "Running Up That Hill"
is Max's hopeful anthem to pull herself out
of the Upside Down in Episode 4.
But Eddie putting himself on the line shows
he's grown up a bit.
Unfortunately, Eddie and Dustin's plan works
a little too well and they have to deal with
a huge swarm of Demobats that assault the
trailer, eventually breaking in through the
vents.
The beasts are small, but they're vicious.
Dustin climbs through the gate back into the
real world, but Eddie severs the makeshift
sheet rope so that he can't come back through
and get hurt.
Obviously, this leaves Eddie trapped in the
Upside Down.
It's a selfless act of heroism, and it proves
that Eddie isn't afraid to grow up and take
responsibility for his own actions.
Although at first it looks like Eddie might
get away from the Demobats on a bike, one
of them knocks it out from underneath him
— and he's suddenly swarmed by the monsters.
Choosing to save Dustin while drawing the
Demobats away from his young sidekick and
the Creel house proves that Eddie has grown
up since the start of the season — when
he jokes about being held back at high school
and refusing to conform with society.
Although Dustin gets back through the gate
to find his friend, he's too late — and
in a heartbreaking goodbye, Eddie passes the
mantle of Dungeon Master on to him, noting
that he didn't run away this time.
Fans have been worried about Eddie's fate
for a while, and this loss definitely hurts
considering how charismatic Joseph Quinn was
in the role.
But at least it had meaning.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about "Stranger
Things: Season 4" are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.